my tie it's Thailand's most ancient
martial art and while it may resemble
western boxing almost anything goes here
hands head feet knees even elbows it's
all legitimate it's thought that ancient
warriors trained in y Thai or Thai
boxing to defend their nation from
invaders now it's one of Thailand's most
popular sports part of every festival
and broadcast throughout the country
every day some of the most successful
boxers got their start here in the
northern hills of Chiang Mai at the e on
my tie training camp today this is home
for 12 year old mana and 15 other
aspiring fighters most are young from
very poor families and are supported by
the camp while here they live to box
training seven hours a day seven days a
week for manat and the others
competitive success here could lead to
better lives physical strength isn't
enough they must be disciplined and
steadfast in their preparation but
modern white-eyed does more than make
warriors out of athletes it makes
dreamers out of boys that wants it
listen if I move on to bigger fights one
day I'll be a champion a champion of
Chiang Mai I'll feel very proud and good
and I'll send the money I went to my
parents
manatsu big night has arrived the fight
is in Hong dome a small village outside
Chiang Mai manat proceeds to the ring
for the wawa an ancient ceremony that
focuses a fighter's strength and power
the fight begins the judges are looking
for good clean sharp techniques both
offense and defensive they are looking
for the boxer who is in control of the
fight firma not tonight is not the night
his opponent is taller heavier and more
experienced but despite those
disadvantages manat makes a strong
showing he loses the fight but he wins
the confidences of his coaches